Oh get down kick come on
oh you swaggin yeah that's all the
little one dobro oh I meant that I got
some good normals so there's only
problem yeah well you're set the counter
right hey hey Dre sex good working okay
so you need to hit him that hard huh
look all right calling you guys I'm
doing this oh we're actually doing a
friendship kiss which is a personal
hundred okay how many are you in right
now we just start I think we're on the
second one you're done
[Music]
Hey sorry about that no no it's fine I
get it you guys left the game it's
really good in this fair you like it
right I get it like a lot I mean I'd get
a nine out of ten right I mean it that
says something but I'm not really like
the hardcore fighting game fan that
maybe you guys are yeah I see the appeal
I understand I mean it's it's so
different for me coming from like a
place where I do not know anything about
animate know anything about Dragon Ball
but this is so reminiscent of like just
what fighting games what I really like
in fighting games like Marvel 3 is
probably my one my favorite fighting
games of all time and this just it feels
so much like a success or more than like
[Music]
for me Marvel was really great in that
it had had a combo system that was so
open just encourage creativity to like
the nth degree or whatever and this kind
of mirrors that in a way even though it
does have like auto combos does it
simplifies a lot of things like all the
characters have the same basic mechanics
that can all super - it all throw the
exact same way but there's still I don't
know something about that this is like
an openness to it that I really really
like so it's really interesting is that
I really don't like Marvel 3 yeah but I
really like this game and I feel like
it's because it marries something that I
haven't liked like I love Dragon Ball
but I haven't for years but something
about the way they've implemented the
things that make Dragon Ball such an
exciting show to watch when it's not you
know boring charging up power right yeah
that's in this game like it's just so
dynamic and fast into like a
hard-hitting
yeah I mean like the awesome thing is
just that you're getting so many
different crowds coming in this game for
different reasons right like you said
you can really watch shouting ball for a
long time but now you're kind of back
into it because of the Dragon Ball like
aesthetics the look and there's
something stylish about the game that
like even if you don't like dragon ball
you can play and feel like you're doing
something like meaningful and like you
know like you're accomplishing these
cool like moments destructive finishes
dramatic finishes things like that and
you're like oh cool how did I do that
[Music]
so get seen all the dramatic finishes
but like how close is it exactly it's
like the enemy like how faithful I guess
the game as a whole the story mode is an
original story right right so they're
definitely doing things differently and
I wouldn't say the story mode has okay
it's not great overall it has like
little moments that really do make you
feel like and I'm watching a new episode
of Dragon Ball Z that's yeah that's not
super it feels like whole Dragon Ball Z
and you can really tell that the
developers so I assume are really big
fans
[Music]
feels like the tiniest details are taken
care of and replicated like really well
it's awesome like I before we even got
like the dramatic finish with like Gohan
and cell I was telling joy I was like
dude you gotta try that I bet you in
this game you make like a huge list of
like all the things like a pause
basically theorycrafting like all these
like anime moments and like going I
wonder if this works wonder if that
works and then like lo and behold like
there's at least a handful that are like
oh that is like almost one-to-one which
is like crazy to think that like they
can do that in a game and almost like
weird too because like you're reliving
some of these moments but like HD
there's still a lot of just variety in
the cast I think um or there's just so
many different styles like I really like
grapplers so I'm glad that they added
like Android 16 and there's a lot of
other characters that like you said are
small but they have long like mix of
potential and I play almost every
character in this game
oh you don't play everyone no I mean
like what I'm trying though you know
like that's yeah what I really get into
you is just sort of the speed of
constantly moving and bringing the fight
to my opponent what yeah that is like I
would say I think the game just has a
whole it encourages like yet aggressive
play because you gain meter when you
move forward right I think like
everything that you do is like
encourages you to keep going at them
it's almost easier to to be aggressive
than have to deal with having to defend
everything now like that's a mark of a
good fighting game person is being able
to defend all those things but if you're
the one that's piling on the aggression
you have to you don't have to think as
much you're like I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do this you deal
with it like I don't have to think about
like what you're gonna do are you gonna
fifty-fifty me me are you gonna overhead
me are you gonna bashing punches like
people did always say oh you can block
10 times in a row but the eleventh one
that one time that you missus yeah
Oklahoma yeah
[Music]
[Music]
all right I feel better about this sorry
I yelled you go finish your match
hopefully didn't break your monitor just
you know just maybe don't tap some good
98 more to go you got now
[Music]